There's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind. I can't control it.
What did you see? Paul.
There is a crusade coming
Do you often dream things that happen, just as you dream them. Yes.
The test is simple, remove your hand from the box and you die.
What's in the box?
Pain
You inherit too much power, you have proven you can rule yourself. Now you must learn to rule others.
Something, none of your ancestors learned
My father rules an entire planet. He's losing it.
He's getting a richer one
He'll lose that one too
Arrakis is a deathtrap
Kill them
This is an extermination
They're picking my family off, one by one
Let's fight like demons
An animal caught in a trap, will knaw off it's own leg to escape. What will you do?
Paul
I know you
One day, the legend will be born
All of civilization depends on it
The future, I can see it.
I must not fear
fear is the mind killer.
My lord duke
When the fear is gone, only I will remain.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This is good to be my dune trailer video.
The sleeper must awaken so there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs here I'll explain what
they're doing with this movie and how they're
covering the story from the first book of
Dune, because this is just meant to be the
first half of the story, of course I'll be
doing videos for the dune series.
So be sure to subscribe to get everything
we'll do a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the trailer on the
video.
So I'll start at the beginning of the trailer
and work our way through shot by shot and
talk about Easter eggs as we go along.
Most of you have probably seen or read at
least some of the dune story or encountered
it at some point in the past one of the most
shared meme moments from any of the dune series
the books is that opening prologue from the
1984 movie Arrakis Dune desert planet with
Virginia Madsen's opening prologue scene.
The funny thing about the song that they put
on this to is actually Pink Floyd from dark
side of the moon.
So just a bit of a wink and a clever Easter
egg on the concept of arrakis Dune desert
planet.
That's the way the book opens.
That's the way the David Lynch's 1984 movie
open to sort of skip over that for the opening
of this trailer because it opens with his
dream as he wakes up he's talking to the Benny
just wrote Rev. mother about the visions that
he's having in the future without understanding
that he's having visions of the future.
He has all this power.
They didn't know about yet sleeper must awaken
he's effectively talking about that in his
voiceover at the beginning.
The trail there's something happening to me.
There's something awakening in my mind as
he has this vision of Chanie in the sun rising
Walder on Arrakis, so obviously this is all
scenes from later in the movie, but is visions
that he's having at the very beginning of
the movie when he talks about seeing the crusade
coming.
That's obvious he the Civil War that happens
on arrakis when the Harkonnens come for them
after their pretrade by Dr. Euie in the Bene
Gesserit Reverend mother then they give you
the scene of the famous test.
Obviously that's a big moment during the 1984
film.
That's a big moment during the books.
The Reverend mother has come to Caladan to
test him to see if he has the power that they
think that he has if he's going to become
the Kwisatz Haderach the result of 10,000
years of selective breeding to create a perfect
being to lead humanity on the golden path
away from their demise while he is the protagonist
of the movie the main character.
The important thing to remember though is
that he's not the most important character
at the beginning of the story.
One of the biggest characters whose driving
the story itself before the events of the
movie pickup is actually his mother, Lady
Jessica and a lot of her choices inform the
really big moves that the plot has during
the story, especially early on, his mother,
Lady Jessica was actually born to the Harkonnen
family, but she's a member of the bandages
her order and they ordered her to marry Duke
Leto and give him a daughter, so they could
wed that daughter to a Harkonnen prince in
this long-running feud with in the galaxy.
So the whole thing is they do want to bring
peace in lead humanity forward, it just the
Bene Gesserit order wants to be in control
of that person that perfect being, but Lady
Jessica winds up falling in love with him
and gives him a son that he wants.
So that's where Paul atreides comes in.
He becomes the vessel for all this power that
the bandages are it has been orchestrating
the Reverend mother has come to see what's
actually going on with and that's what she's
asking these questions.
Do you often have visions of things that come
to pass the concept of genetic memory is very
important to the dune mythology the Rev. mother
at any given time of the bandages.
Her order possesses sort of like the sum total
of all knowledge and memories from previous
generations.
But Paul Atreides becoming the Kwisatz Haderach
also gains all those memories when he says
I can see the future.
That's actually part of his powers the Kwisatz
Haderach he can actually see the golden path,
but the whole thing about all this power that's
bestowed on him.
Is it actually becomes a bit of a trap.
I don't of the going to deal with this during
the movie the pie address it at some point,
but he himself becomes sort of trapped within
his own destiny and becomes a big problem
for him later on.
Lady Jessica also winds up giving birth to
a little girl a Leah after Duke Leto his diet
and she also gains those powers when she takes
in the waters of life, so effectively you
have to characters with the powers of the
Kwisatz Haderach in the dune series.
I was a most of the trailer is just focusing
on the first half of the story, though with
him meeting the sand worms the sleeper must
awaken that big iconic moment from the 1984
film the sort of the moment when he eventually
takes the waters of life in his power start
to awaken within him.
He becomes conscious of his abilities.
What are the differences between this film
and the 1984 film, though, is that the David
Lynch movie blew through a lot of the plot
within that one movie, so you have to imagine
that most of this will encompass the big Civil
War that happens on arrakis him meeting the
friend and meeting Chani and learning about
his powers, then the second half of the story
will be what he does.
Once he unlocks those abilities.
I love the scene of him putting his hand in
the box.
Everybody remembers this from the 1984 film
fear is the mind killer as he slowly starts
to sense all these crazy things happening
to it.
This is the same scene from the 1984 film
of him fighting with gurney played by Josh
Brolin thanos himself Oscar Isaac who's playing
Duke Leto made all kinds of Josh Brolin jokes
when the cast was doing there big interview
for the movie earlier he sort of their war
master.
He's the one is teaching Paul to fight before
all the craziness of the actual plot of the
story.
Their whole ideas that eventually one day
Paul will take over the family once Duke Leto
dies of natural causes.
Obviously that doesn't wind up happening.
Gurney is one of his most important teachers
early on before all this happens when the
bandages right mother is talking to about
learning to rule himself and rule others.
Obviously that's all just foreshadowing for
later in the movie was he becomes the most
powerful person in the universe is also a
bit of foreshadowing for the eventual God
Emperor of Dune story which is something that
Paul atreides gets too involved in that's
all about the golden path leading humanity
forward every was kind of hoping that if the
movies are really successful actually do the
story of his son, Duke Leto the second who
becomes God Emperor of Dune is a giant giant
TV series when the Reverend mother is talking
about his father losing the planet just foreshadowing
the events of the big betrayal this going
to be happening later in the movie, so it's
not that they hate Duke Leto and they want
to get rid of house of treaties, it just that
they feel like the only way to achieve this
golden path now based on current events is
to throw him under the bus.
I love the production design.
I love the look of the sand worms everything
looks great.
Obviously they try to go back to a lot of
the original Frank Herbert dune concept art
for their designs really cool Easter egg hereto
when their ships are landing on arrakis don't
these look a little bit like jobless and crawlers.
So if you're not a huge fan of the dune series.
What you might not realize is is that George
Lucas was actually inspired by a lot of what
Frank Herbert did with that first dune book
when he was writing the Star Wars stories
and doing the original trilogy, but really
it's not them trying to do Star Wars with
dune.
The reason why looks a little bit like Star
Wars is because Star Wars itself was inspired
by that original dune stuff we get our first
look at the beast played by Dave Batista.
I'm sure he's going to be amazing monster
during the movie, we get our first look at
Stellan Skarsgard who's playing Baron Harkonnen
himself as we see them landing on the planet
we meet Jason Momoa is Duncan Idaho for the
first time he's actually one of the first
people as part of the Dukes forces to meet
the fragment when the Emperor tells Duke Leto
that he is now in charge of spice production
and has to move his family to arrakis he sends
Duncan Idaho there ahead of their forces to
sort of get the lay of the land a lot of people
don't realize those early in the story the
planet arrakis itself is one of the most important
characters in the dune story through all of
the dune novels because of its relationship
with the sand worms and the spice itself is
that the sand worms themselves that create
the spice that so critical to the function
of the universe teaser for faster than light
travel.
It has all kinds of medicinal properties all
kinds of psychedelic properties is sort of
like this wonder drug that does.
So many different things, but it's only produced
on this one planet, but most of the universe
does not realize that the sand worms themselves
are what create the spice so it's really the
sand worms themselves the most important resource
in the universe and when the Rev. mother says
one day the legend will be born all of civilization
depends on it.
She's actually talking about Paul's son.
She's not talking about Paul himself, but
I don't know if there actually to get to that
in any of the movies say that for eventual
children of dune series.
If you're wondering why there's not a whole
lot of Sunday is Chani character in this trailer.
There's a lot of shots of her early on, but
she said that she's not really big during
this first part of the story should probably
going to be a much bigger character during the
sequel that just because he doesn't really
encounter her till after this big revolt and
it sounds like that's going to take up most
of the events of this first movie I love the
reveal of the sand worms to business not look
so much like the original concept art, and
just gives you an idea for the scale of things
just how massive the sand worms can get, but
everyone let me know in the comments.
What your most hyped up about this.
I'll be just a small part of the story.
Like I said this is going to be a two-part
story for the first book the movie supposed
to come out in December.
Hopefully theaters will all be open everywhere
we connection go to a theater and see it,
but I'll be more trailers in the next couple
month so course I'll do videos when they drop.
That new footage everyone click here for my
brand-new Chadwick Boseman Black Panther video
and click here for that brand-new Mandalorian
season 2 teaser think you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!